hello there fortnight chapter 2 season 7
has given us a brand new alien invasion
storyline to follow as well as
continuing to slowly gift us with more
information about the imagined order and
the loop we are stuck in with the event
to mark the end of the season and this
part of the storyline it's time for a
full recap of the last three months so
if you'd kindly sit your butt down for
10 minutes and think about using code
adamaru in the fortnite shop now let's
recap the season
during the final week of season six it
became apparent season seven would be
themed around an alien invasion as crop
circles appeared and occasionally
players would be abducted
and then this happened the biggest alien
ship you've ever seen engulfed the
island and it became clear what they
wanted traveling straight to the zero
point which was secured by the
foundation and agent jones a season
prior and this is our first uncertain
moment to speak of is the zero point
destroyed
we've been told its destruction would
break all reality so that leaves two
main theories one the zero point was
taken by the alien race or two the zero
point is back below ground with io
either way the central point of the
island became a crater and the
foundation was thrown into an unknown
body of water the aftermath of the
explosion left the remnants of the spire
combined with the dna of the chimera
homeworld resulting in small alien
biomes sprouting around the island
little did we know this was part of
their plan they want to take over the
entire island immediately the imagined
order sprang into action led by dr sloan
a child genius who rose up the ranks of
io she was also the one attempting to
stop jones switching sides and we know
that plan failed io constructed multiple
monitoring stations and recruited from
many dimensions including rick sanchez
to assist in the impending war against
the alien visitors as the aliens brought
new tech so did i oh the war continually
shifted for weeks but not everyone felt
like this over at sweaty sands some of
the locals were visibly delighted to see
the aliens appear the poi became believe
a beach and was emblazoned with
everything celebrating the ufo above us
back to io and dr sloane sloan was
staying out of reach of the mother ship
in a secret bunker deep below the
farmland of connie complex here research
and intel was being formulated
everything from the mothership size to
its flight plan to a mysterious
bomb-like image on the monitors more on
that later io were planning something
and as the weeks went by we became part
of that plan suddenly the mothership
opened to release drop ships abductors
that would beam players into the
mothership to run tests and experiments
in here we were given alien tech and
sent to battle for rewards the weird
thing was the mother ship had pois from
as far back as the original fortnite
island from the butterban a few seasons
prior all the way back to sunny steps
and lucky landing before we asked too
many questions the henchbros returned
the bromance that lasted since midas
waged war between ghost and shadow and
our questions went unanswered back on
dry land and io were on the hunt for an
imposter among them someone was giving
information to the alien race it was
confirmed that joey was actually one of
the aliens posing as a human breaking
into io's secret bunker yet there was
another working with the aliens but we
didn't find out who for another two
months after four weeks on the island a
change was seen over at holly hedges the
aliens were converting it into an
environment they could safely live in
their home world flora and fauna arose
and once they added anti-gravity fields
holly hedges became holly hatchery and
alien eggs were spotted everywhere even
on the lobby screen growing in numbers
each week dr sloane and io made an
important observation this week the
aliens love cat food they desire it more
than any other food source on the island
and that became part of sloane's plan in
an unforeseen update the duo we call
bill and ted the hench bros were seen
traveling around the island they were in
a house one week they're at the driving
cinema the next but halfway through the
season the shadow brother hit a eureka
moment we don't know what this is but
these equations on this whiteboard are
the same as ios and sloan's hard work in
the secret i o facility his brother by
the way was practicing shooting outside
this was also the update we did
something we should not be proud of
working with sloane has its ups and
downs and this time sloan told us to
wipe the memories of anyone on the
island who knows too much about io one
of those people was bunker jonesy who
once again was so close to piecing
everything together just like he did in
chapter one and then we wiped his memory
sorry john the old chum this shows us
though that dr sloan operates between
the lines of good and evil all in the
name of the imagined order and that
reminds me of another bombshell we
should talk about
this season also gave us the climax of
the batman fortnite zero point comic
book series season six saw batman
trapped in the loop and by leaving
messages for himself he was slowly able
to figure out more about the loop than
anyone ever has before with the help of
catwoman we now know that a sole
survivor of a match can escape the loop
if they are in the very center of the
final circle outside the loop the
survivors are free to look around the
island but a hidden death barrier keeps
them all captive here batman was able to
locate and open one of the bunkers we
continuously look at and got all the way
down into the isle stronghold below long
story short down there is the zero point
still accessible but not only that once
batman found a way to get everyone back
to their own dimensions we are given a
piece of info about none other than dr
sloan she was behind the scheme to bring
batman into fortnite working with lex
luthor and the batman who laughs so dr
sloane is working with the criminals
this series ended with a rift created in
metropolis the home of superman and now
back to the game superman is here right
away it's highly likely that dr sloan
wants him here to fight in the alien
invasion this once again muddies the
waters of whether dr sloan and io are
the good guys or downright evil what do
you say
nine weeks into the invasion now and
things escalated both sides brought new
tech to win the war including a cow and
a device that lets you be graeme the
gnome good memories the mother ships
circled the island before settling over
slurpee swamp without warning the vessel
opened and began to rip that poi out of
the ground crumbling apart slurpee swamp
vanished totally gone it was only later
we realised that entire poi now lived in
the mothership like before as soon as we
started asking questions something took
our attention away and this time it was
a concert the rooftop posters appeared
until the day ariana and the rest of the
tour arrived the concert was respite
from the war but it actually is part of
fortnite law the invaders set up the
rift tour as a chance to scan our
thoughts and memories can you believe it
ariana was a decoy all along during the
early parts of the event we were sucked
into a corridor of memories our memories
from the history of fortnite from the
butterfly event to singularity's mech to
the rocket event which began all of this
and even the sacred cube we call kevin
made an appearance the aliens were
looking through our memories of the loop
to find answers that day one of the
images was not a memory as it hasn't
actually happened yet the cube was
actually on the current map here in
chapter two did the alien shows the
future while showing us our past
have we been looping so long we don't
remember kevin arriving so many
questions left unanswered but one piece
of information is more important than
all the rest the alien invaders have an
official name they are called the last
reality now we know the last reality
plans to take over the entire island
through terraforming which they
successfully accomplished at holly
hatchery and then joey the former alien
spy let us in on the full plan it's
quite simple the invasion is here to
wipe us all out every single looper
so it would appear we are on the side of
io this time around and sloane is
working hard to give us a chance to
survive dr sloane wants to cause the
mother ship to crash land onto the
island causing irrevocable damage but
ultimately winning the war as the mother
ship moved over to coral castle we said
our goodbyes to that poi and once again
it was taken into the mothership leaving
nothing but destruction behind and this
became the moment sloan played her hand
to trick the invaders into taking an
atomic bomb on board the mothership all
those weeks prior we saw the bomb right
in front of our eyes and never realized
its importance and now sloan makes it
our job to activate it
season seven had another unexpected
edition out of nowhere the new imposter
mode released and once again it was
filled with official law set deep in the
isle facility we are tasked with finding
the mole the impostor attempting to undo
the imagined order's work it's
insinuated that agent jones had help
when he defected last season other
things we know include the fact io have
been controlling the island for
thousands of years we've run things
successfully for thousands of years
thousands i thought it was four i was
very wrong inside the facility we know
the bridge is fully intact from the
season five reveal and the batman comic
book and the zero point is here too all
this by the way is the main reason i
asked you at the start of the video if
you thought the last reality took the
zero point or i o returned it back
underground the evidence is not
completely clear yet so let's keep both
options open in the final week of the
season we are set two additional tasks
by dr sloan the first is to warn the
folks in the crash zone of the mother
ship should the plan be successful so it
shows you that she does actually care at
least a little bit but the second task
is a little more daunting i all knew
about a mole in their ranks we all
assumed it was joey but the real culprit
is actually maven it's now a race
against time to uncover what the last
reality know about operation sky fire
and if maven can be convinced to share
everything she knows about the
opposition sloan's final task reminds us
our place in this story there is no room
at io for traitors maven will soon learn
that i hope you remember it too right
now the aliens have fallen for dr
sloane's plan the farmland around corny
complex is being dragged into the mother
ship once again all thanks to a few
well-placed cat food containers those
aliens really can't resist it the cycle
is repeating and this time io are ready
to take advantage bombs covering the
ascending poi will soon be inside the
alien ship on september 12th operation
sky fire begins and we will be the lead
agents boarding the mothership to end
this invasion once and for all now it's
time to infiltrate the last reality and
put a stop to the alien occupation we've
received the mothership blueprint we
have a prototype backpack ready to go so
suit up for the event visit the tiny
chair one last time keep an eye on the
hench bros and say goodbye to the latest
addition to hut watch which will likely
be destroyed rip i'm adam from
playstation grenade thank you very much
for watching here's some code adamaru
legends
[Music]
oh